- [Mark] All right.
What's, what's your name?
- [Carlton] Carlton Beard.
- Carl Carlton Beard.
Where are you from Carlton?
- Actually, I was born
in Fresno, California
but I moved to Houston,
Texas when I was two.
So that's where I was raised at.
- So you're a Texan?
- Yes, sir.
- Basically. How long you been out here?
- Well, well, I've been
in Skid Row since 2013.
- What brought you out here?
- Well, actually,
actually 2006, I came from
I came from Houston, Texas
to Sacramento to see my mom
my mom and my two younger brothers moved
from Texas to Sacramento in '89.
And I didn't see my mom no more till 2006.
So I, I went to see my mom.
So and,
so I came to Sacramento
and, and, and
after, after I was in
Sacramento for a while,
and you know, I've been
through Reno and, and all that,
and Vallejo and Oakland stuff, I wanted to
I wanted to see Hollywood,
wanted to see Hollywood
so I started asking some questions about
about LA and everybody,
everybody that I was
talking to in Sacramento
they like, "we don't go to LA,
we don't go to LA for, for what?"
And so, I just wanted
to see it and you know
so I came, you know and
it was
I had already had a drug
problem when I came,
you know so, it it it got
(?), span out of control
Span out of control,
you know, you ended up in prison,
you end up in prison
but I had already done
time before in Texas
and California prison is, is
is nothing, is nothing like Texas.
N'am saying? So, so
- How are they different?
- Well, well, well, California prison,
you have to stand up on
your own two feet as a man.
If the people from your, you
your city or from your
neighborhood, see that you, you know
you're still on your own two feet as man
and then then they'll back
you, then your back you
if you get into some, you
know, some major altercations.
And California prison
is a lot different, man.
It's like, is like,
say like, if I'm from, if I'm from,
if I'm from Long Beach, if I'm
from Long Beach, California
and I'm a in, I'm in California prison
and I do something that
I shouldn't have done,
it can start it a riot, it,
it just can get ugly man,
it can get ugly.
- What's your drug?
- Actually, actually heroin.
- You're doing heroin?
- Yeah, yeah. I been,
I've been snorting heroin off and on
since I been 15 years old.
Yeah, the only reason I ain't
never stuck a needle in my arm
is cause I'm scared of needles.
So it always been the (?).
And from the first time I
did it, I remember saying,
I remember saying, "damn"
- It's just addictive right?
- Yeah, yeah. I remember
saying, first time I,
when I first did, I remember saying "Damn,
this feels like the best
feeling in the world".
And,
and
every, every other
every other, every other
heroin addict say same thing.
- How do you, how do you
support your condition?
- Well, well, I, I do a little hustling.
I might, I might, I might,
I might
I might know somebody that needs something
and I played a middleman and
and I made sure everybody,
everybody's satisfied,
everybody's, everybody
that's involved in this
'lil business arrangement,
everybody's satisfied.
I just make sure everybody
is fair, everybody's fair.
You know, because then greed kick in,
all types of, and then, and then
- So that kinda means,
so in other words you're a pimp right?
- Well I, I wouldn't say
I w I wouldn't say
I wouldn't say I'm a pimp,
I'm a participant, I'm a participant,
I'm a hub, you know?
Pimp sounds vulgar,
it sounds, it sounds, it sounds like
somebody street named
"Sugar Nuts", you know
- A participator or a a facilitator
- Yeah, yeah and a person
who's providing a service,
providing a service and, and
he's he's keeping it honest,
he's keeping it respectful.
- Keep everybody happy.
- Yeah. And, and, and you have
you have longevity in
whatever you're doing.
- In your community.
- Yeah. Yeah.
Truly, money money's root of all evil man.
Money, money.
Money sets, money sets a fire on your ass.
It sets a fire on your ass man.
I've seen a fire that
wouldn't necessarily be there
if he was broke, if he was broke.
And so,
I don't know, but
I actually think that
I'm just as much addicted to
hustling and the lifestyle
because that come along with it man,
that come along with it. And
Yeah.
- What, how did you get
introduced to heroin first?
Who first turned you on to it?
- My uncle's friends.
In Texas, my uncle had
about three friends in
in Dell's (?).
And, and, every now and
then, every now and then,
they'll go, they'll go pull a,
they'll go pull a nice robbery.
And
So when his friends came over to him
he came over to my house.
He came to my house.
He came into my house, and,
and and I'll never forget,
He had, he had a big Mercury Marquis,
And this my uncle's friend,
And he said, "Man, you think
you can drive that car?"
So I said "Man",
I said,
"Man I've been driving since
I been 12 years old man".
And, and my grandfather
had his own business
in Houston, Texas, for 54 years, man.
He had three brick house
built from the ground up.
And, he did all this by selling dirt.
Pot,
yeah.
And so,
yeah he has me get
He has, he has me get and drive it.
So that's yeah, he says
"Get up, go down there",
He says "Go down there..."
Yeah
- So do you have kids of your own?
- Yeah, I have two daughters man,
And it's like, it's like, it's
like the joy in my life, man.
It's like, my youngest
daughter named Jessica.
She, she graduated from the
University of Texas in Austin.
And she's, she's a coach now.
And
Yeah
Yeah, I have two daughters.
Yeah my youngest daughter named Jessica
and last year she graduated
from the University of Texas.
And my oldest daughter named Brandy.
She graduated, graduated from TSU,
Texus of the University,
that's in Houston, Texas
where I'm from, so yeah so
Yeah man.
I thank the Lord that I had two daughters
instead of two sons, man.
- Because?
- Because I had two sons,
man, they'll probably be
in the cell next door to me.
- Oh you did prison time?
- Of course, of course I did prison time.
- What for? Drugs?
- Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
And it had a soul and a soul.
- Where do you see, where do
you see your life going here
from here?
- Straight to the top,
man, I got a testimony man.
I got a testimony man.
N'am saying, n'am saying?
If,
if you wouldn't, if
Yeah, so sorry about that man.
- It's okay.
- What was, what was the next question?
Oh, where I see my life going from here?
And man,
God, God got a job for me to do man.
He got a job for me to do
and, and, and, and, and yeah.
Yeah, man.
And, and, and I.
Yeah, man, it's just
I'm
I'm really ready, I'm
really ready truly to,
to stop getting high.
Yeah
- All right, well, thank you
very much for talking with me
good luck with everything.
- Thank you. Thank you
- Do your thing
- Yes sir, yes sir.